This is the exact same problem
that I did in the last video,
but I realized after
looking at the problem
that I just mindlessly
did the problem.
But there's actually a much
simpler way of doing it.
So once again, they're telling
us to subtract and state
the difference in simplest form.
And what I did in
the last video is,
I just said, OK, let's
find a common denominator.
And then I found it, and
then I did the subtraction.
But what I could
have done, and that
would have simplified
all of the math,
is I could have simplified each
of these expressions first.
So let's do that.
So this first expression right
over here, both the numerator
and the denominator
is divisible by m.
So let's divide them both by m.
If you divide the
numerator by m, you get 1.
You divide the denominator
by m, m squared divided by m
is just m.
The second term right
over here, both of them,
both the numerator and the
denominator, are divisible by n
to the third power.
So let's divide the numerator
by n to the third power.
You get a 1.
You divide the denominator,
you divide n to the fourth
by n to the third power,
you just get an n.
And so we can rewrite
this as 6-- 6 times 1,
so that's just 6-- 6
over 7mn, minus 5--
because that's just
5 times 1-- over 3mn.
And this really
simplifies the problem.
So let's think about a
common denominator over here.
So it's going to be
something minus something.
So a common denominator has to
be divisible by both 7 and 3.
So the least common
multiple of 7 and 3 is 21.
And it has to be
divisible by m, and it
has to be divisible by n.
21mn, and that also
takes care of this.
21mn is clearly
divisible by 7mn,
and it's clearly
divisible by 3mn.
It's got the mn there.
It's divisible by 3,
it's divisible by 7.
So that's our least
common multiple,
or you could say it's
our common denominator.
And to get from 7mn to 21mn,
you've got to multiply by 3.
And if you're multiplying
the denominator by 3,
you've got to multiply
the numerator by 3.
And you get 3 times
6 is equal to 18.
And to go from 3mn to 21mn,
you've got to multiply by 7.
I'll do it over here, you've
got to multiply it by 7.
And if you multiply
the denominator by 7,
you've got to multiply
the numerator by 7
if you don't want to change
the value of the expression.
So 5 times 7 is equal to 35.
And then so this is going
to be equal to 18 minus 35,
since we have-- let
me write it down--
we have a common
denominator here of 21mn.
And we're going to have
to calculate 18 minus 35
in the numerator.
I'll just write it over here,
18 minus 35 in the numerator.
And 18 minus 35 is negative 17.
So we get negative 17 in
the numerator, over 21mn,
and we are done.
And I think that was
a good bit simpler
than the way we did
it in the last video.